hi oh man i'm i'm great actually life is
so fun
life is good right now yeah higher
learning's doing well higher learning is
doing really well
yeah it's a good movie i saw that we've
had uh some of the cast on
already on the show did you yeah and uh
we had the director on and
it was uh yeah it's a very good movie i
went and saw it i enjoyed it a lot john
boy he's a great guy isn't he yeah
intense very nice man he intense yeah he
takes his work so seriously it's
wonderful
yeah now you finished the movie how long
ago
uh it was like that was a while ago that
was that was
that was summer-ish time that was like
august right so finished
this movie was done for you a little
while ago and and you took a trip
right you took a trip afterwards because
i thought this was really unusual you
went to
where was it i wanted to bet you want
you to bet yes
because not many people do that when
they wrap a movie say yeah now it's time
for me to cool off and go to tibet yeah
it's kind of a wanderlust sort of thing
it's like
it's a it's a free roaming you know i
grew up in woodstock
you know upstate new york so i had this
sort of like wandering hippie aspect to
myself so
i had to uh no i don't actually but then
but
but i love them i would like to um but i
yeah i did i went to tibet i went
trekking it's it's an absolutely
beautiful place i was there for a month
i was uh camping for really so you
didn't just
you didn't just go to tibet and stay
like in a luxury five-star hotel you
actually
walked around yeah yeah i was i walked
to the around the um
east face hi does anyone ever like talk
to you sometimes sometimes they do it's
fine
he won't bite he's nice
so i i was uh no i was i was camping i
walked to the east face of mount everest
um it's called the kangchang face i walk
to uh
to land's end it's like eight we went up
to like eighteen thousand feet
and uh this is certain doesn't that like
where the oxygen stops
yeah it gets it it gets pretty pretty
verified up there i need oxygen to get
by i don't know about you but it was
great i mean i
didn't take a shower for for a month
which i had never done before
really yeah i was i mean i was in a tent
i had like a little they they came with
washing water every morning and then
tomorrow you went a month without
bathing yeah i did
it was spectacular
my hair looked really good by then i had
this and it was so
cold you know because it was i mean it
was it's mount everest it's cold it's
cold air and glaciers wind whipping all
this kind of stuff
so i i had this hat that i would wear
every day and boy my hair was just like
stuck
inside that hat it was it was it was
this is a really disgusting picture
actually you're painting yeah
now what happens to you when you're just
i mean because you're you're walking
around tibet
sort of like cane and kung fu you're not
showering
you know you're getting really dirty and
sweaty did your personality change at
all when you did this
i was uh i felt myself to be like a blue
sheep
actually a what a blue
sheep not
okay no it's you just went somewhere
really great man
you're right it was like uh you just
took a weird trip
man what it's sort of it's sort of it's
sort of a an
animalistic thing that happens i think
being in the mountains it's like you
know you get you
if there's none of this there's none of
this stuff that you're supposed to do
it's like
all you have to do is like wake up at
sunrise and walk
so it's like what do you do what are you
going to do with your day it's like
it's really wonderful all these like
layers of things that seem to be
important but really aren't
sort of fall away just all kind of just
disappear
and so you became like an animal
look at my teeth see them yeah you've
got a fang actually exactly
wow me i just like to go to like a
really nice hotel and watch cable
no yeah that's just but that's me here's
me conan that scares me i know very
stuff falls away that way no layers
layers crumble there start to find
what's important
right cinemax very important um now did
uh did you
what do they have in tibetan tibet is
where they have yaks right they have
yaks in tibet they have yaks they have
yak they have
many things they have yaks and yak
products up the wazoo
they have uh they have this is what are
you talking like yak jerky
no they what they have is uh they drink
yak butter tea
they have butter lamps made of yak
butter that's the fuel that that they
burn by they smear the yak they bring
the egg butter to the monasteries and
offer it to the gods the yak butter
and they put it in their hair and on
their skin is kind of like a moisturizer
and they also use yak dung
as uh as fires which has a great smell
let's just yeah romantic evening around
a yak dung fire
eating yak jerky great it's great stuff
that's incredible yeah i just picture a
whole country where literally everything
is made out of a yak in some form or
another people are like driving around
in dried out yaks with motors in them
that's that's an interesting imagination
you got there oh i'm a weird freak
uh now uh power to you huh yeah yeah
thank you very much um so you're away
all this time you mentioned a monastery
did you actually go and see a monastery
yeah i went to many
monasteries very very very beautiful um
i would think you would be a distraction
in a monastery you know if i had
do you know what i mean aren't they
supposed to be away from women and
aren't they supposed to be kind of very
pure and
they have people they have people coming
in um
you know what's wonderful about the
monks there is that it's they're not
like um
they don't they don't have any
affectations of
um holiness so they're not like really
sober all the time they're laughing
they're having a good time they're like
joking around they're playing with one
another
it's really nice they don't feel
what no no
goofy monks is a very fun image it's not
it's like i mean i was
i was shocked actually i expected
everyone to be like you know very quiet
and like this all the time but they're
not they're like joking around
and you said they're not sober i just
imagined a lot of drinking
exactly monks hanging out of the tower
yeah but you know it's but you know
we rule yeah what's um what's beautiful
um about them is that uh they're
they're very open to people i mean if
you if you sort of come in and look
interested in what they're doing they
um very much like to um
share their experience with you and uh
introduce you to their culture
and and let you partake in what they're
doing so for example
i was uh went to see um hear them chant
because you know they do this beautiful
chanting um
and i was in this place called the
jokong monastery and it's a sacred
sacred temple and everything and they
have very young monks too they start
when they're very young
and they were like in this enclosed area
and uh
they saw me like looking at them like
this i was so fascinated
and they let me come in and sit um
with the monks and then i was you know
it was kind of like sitting sitting far
back
they were up there and there was this
like 12 year old little monk kept like
looking back
12 year old mom i mean that's a huge
decision to make at 12.
they start when they're like five they
start really you know yeah but anyway he
like
i was staring at this this kid he was
like so it was so wonderful to me
and he kind of like waves me over and
rolls out this little piece of carpet
for me
and i sat right behind him i was sitting
like this close to him and he was like
so happy he was like
nodding like yeah this is where it said
and i thought it was really
really beautiful and they come over and
they give you like um an older monk came
and gave me this white scarf which is a
symbolic gesture they do it and
it's like a it's like a blessing i bet
you it was made of yak
yes some kind of yeah it smelled of yak
smelled like yeah that sounds like
that's a cool trip though it sounds like
it's so beautiful do you feel like now
it must be weird to be back you're back
now and you're riding around in cabs and
chewing bubble gum what happens fast
listening to a walkman but i still have
my picture of the dalai lama what where
is it oh down there
oh cool you actually have a little
picture of the dalai lama
is his picture on everything else is it
like elvis there is it just their plates
um actually it's it's uh it's illegal
which is very sad
oh that's right not allowed to have they
can't have it that's right of
the uh of the dalai lama which is sad so
where did you get that you actually got
that there
this was contraband oh yeah it was um
someone that uh was there that i
befriended over there
had this and you know a lot of people
have them they just hide them and he
wound up giving it to me
actually which was touching yeah it was
very nice
and uh the movie is uh go higher
learning
we're out of time but uh higher learning
is a movie people should check that out
yeah and uh yeah and you just you're
working on a movie right now is that
right
or you just finished wrapping it or
something no i have another one that's
going to come out in october
or november probably do you want to just
mention the name of it it's called of
love and shadows
all right people should watch that it's
very nice meeting you thanks for coming
sounds like a new
everybody we'll be right back with
sister gene kenny